der höchsten schulabschluss den
deutschland zu bieten hat 400.000
schüler bereiten sich in diesem moment
darauf vor den wichtigsten test ihres
lebens zu absolvieren
bestehen sie ihn so stehen ihnen alle
türen offen
das abitur vor vier jahren habe ich nach
zwölf langen schuljahren kurz vor dem
allgemeinen abitur die schule
abgebrochen
diese woche finde ich heraus ob ich das
zeug dazu passt oder nicht ich werde
zuerst unvorbereitet das bayerische
mathematik abitur schreiben um zu sehen
wie schlecht ich bin dann eine woche all
day every day im internet lehrende
methoden die mir spaß machen um das
mathe abi am ende erneut anzutreten und
herauszufinden ob und mit welcher note
ich bestehe
dieses video wird mal wieder von mir
selbst unterstützt in der video
beschreibung findet ihr den trailer zu
einem schnittkurs mit dem man schnell
alles lernen was einem schnitt von
musikvideos urlaubsvideos oder für
youtube-videos brauche jetzt wird's
ernst ich kriege jetzt das mathe abitur
was ich unvorbereitet bestehen muss
vielen dank so viel die das ganze
vorbereitet hat das sieht gar nicht gut
aus ok arbeitszeit 90 minuten und ich
mein taschenrechner formelsammlung o2
und die zeit läuft ab jetzt doch wie ist
das mathe abitur eigentlich aufgebaut
und was kommt kann grob gesagt besteht
das zu 50 prozent aus analysis sprich
funktion und deren graphen auf ihre
eigenschaften zu untersuchen und
beschreiben zu 25 prozent aus stochastik
also wahrscheinlichkeit und
kombinationsmöglichkeiten zu berechnen
und zu 25 prozent aus geometrie also
dreidimensionale objekte und der anlage
zueinander berechnen es besteht im
detail aus einem teil der ohne
taschenrechner und merkhilfe absolviert
werden muss und einem teil bei dem die
beiden hilfsmittel erlaubt sind beide
teile beinhalten zwei ähnliche aufgaben
gruppen jeweils von analysis stochastik
und geometrie der lehrerstreik dann
jeweils eine der beiden aufgaben gucken
weg in der regel die von der er denkt
dass sie für seine schüler schwere ist
für den teil hat einen schüler 90
minuten zeit um möglichst viele der 40
maximalen bewertungs anhalten zu
kassieren für den teil wie sind es 180
minuten und 80 bewertungs einheiten
geben jeweils den schirm einer in
definierten periodischen punkt
nach dem stochastik also daher setzt
wirklich komplett auf ich glaube nicht
dass ich darf noch eine frage richtig
haben werde
aber wie wird das abitur eigentlich
benotet in der oberstufe gibt es keine
noten mehr von 16 sondern notenpunkte
von 0 bis 15 mein ziel sind mindestens
fünf noten punkte was einer glatten 4
entspricht denn erst dann hat man
bestanden ohne zu unterpunkten für
dieses ziel bräuchte ich mindestens 45
der maximalen 120 bewertungs einhalten
also ganze 45 ja gar kein plan ich habe
keine ahnung mehr wie so was geht gar
kein plan
ja das wird nix kann ich nicht kann ich
nicht kann ich nicht denn ich perfekt
ich hätte noch eine stunde setzten sie
nun über gehabt das wird jetzt zur
korrektur eingeschickt und sagen bin ich
gespannt ob ich vielleicht einen punkt
haben um herauszufinden ob ich ohne
vorbereitung schon bestanden hätte
werden alle blätter eingescannt und dann
meine schwester einer matte leo
verwenden geschickt okay lasst mich auf
jeden fall sehr bemüht wow
seine schrift bild ist aber auch
wirklich draußen hat die neue werte
erfunden ist eine wortneuschöpfung haben
wir mal zu den harten fakten 75 punkte
erreicht dadurch nur 7,5 da gibt's
nämlich insgesamt 60 punkte wenn ich in
geometrie da hast du von 30 punkten ganz
nett 3,5 und sehr leicht weil das ja
noch schlechter ich dachte da war ich
gut und bei stochastik straßen sonst und
eine ganze 10 5 das ist voll starker ich
hatte stochastik noch nie in der schule
ja dann hätten wir dann 21,5 und ich
glaube für den ersten noten punkte 24
gebraucht aber ganz knapp nur 0 punkte
ja aber es war leider nicht okay ich
habe null punkte aber ganz knapp
und deswegen würde ich sagen
das klingt auf jeden fall hier sehen mit
dem bestehen das ist ja traurig ich habe
das wirklich überhaupt keinen plan wenn
er jetzt hier zum beispiel ex
rauskriegen will milow gerät muss dann
gibt's hier irgendwie in der basis und
dann gibt es ja irgendwie eine nicht was
ist also eigentlich dass die basis damit
in nur einer woche aus einer glatten 6
eine gute note wird hätte ich zusammen
mit sowie einen schlachtplan aus da an
alles alleine ganze 50 prozent der note
ausmacht konzentriere ich mich
hauptsächlich darauf mit dreieinhalb
tagen stochastik beziehungsweise
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung hatte ich in
meiner schullaufbahn noch nie
deshalb widme ich ihr immerhin
anderthalb tage geometrie macht 25
prozent aus deshalb hoffe ich mit nur
einem tag wiederholungen genug bewirken
zu können an jedem abend wird das bisher
gelernte zwei stunden wiederholt all das
um mich am ende erneut der abiprüfung zu
stellen die prüfung die ich vorhin ohne
vorbereitung gemacht habt die wahl
übrigens von 2014 für den finalen test
wäre ich natürlich eine andere prüfung
nehmen zum lern habe ich mir hier ein
ebook hole in den wirklich alles
drinsteht was ich können muss und jetzt
geht es direkt los mit stochastik
[Musik]
es ist so ein komisches gefühl einfach
zu lernen nach dir ja und es macht echt
einfach gerade spaß mich da rein zu
fixen ich hatte noch nie so viel ich
habe noch nie spaß und das zusätzlich zu
meinem lernen ebook schaue ich mir zu
jedem einzelnen unternehmer gezielt 38
minütige videos auf youtube an mit
dieser taktik komme ich sehr gut durch
und habe das thema stochastik in knapp
fünf stunden zur hälfte abgearbeitet so
wenn dann bin ich jetzt wirklich an den
punkt gekommen wo ich mich einmal da
ging nichts mehr
egal wie ich nicht angeschlagen habe es
hat einfach nicht mehr funktioniert
trotzdem war ich aber meistens motiviert
eine gute leistung abzuliefern und es
hat mich nicht interessiert aber morgen
werde ich auf jeden fall ein paar pausen
einplanen damit nicht direkt die
schnauze voll hat tag 28 uhr morgens
geht es weiter mit stochastik ich mache
doch ein paar aufgaben von der
abiprüfung gestern die ich frauen
bestimmen sie die wahrscheinlichkeit
dafür dass unter den 100 befragten
jugendlichen genau 85 ein computer
besitzen ich weiß wie das geht ist
gleich 8,07 prozent
das stimmt aber das ging ja wirklich
flüssig das ist richtig geiles gefühl
das ist ein echt geiles gefühl bei der
nächsten aufgabe hier sieht es aber
schon wieder ein bisschen schwieriger
aus klar die wir natürlich immer spieler
die weiteren runden geht an das wäre
also krass und das ding am ende aber
bestehen würde
doch diese anfängliche motivation soll
nicht von dauer sein denn nach nur zwei
stunden
es geht gar nichts mehr also ich bin
jetzt kann das ist wieder dran aber die
konsole komplett reckt und ich habe es
auch einfach nicht welche themen die
werden logischerweise immer schwieriger
wie soll ich wissen wie groß die anzahl
derjenigen personen die sowohl als mal
von aus auf eine feste spiele konsole
besitzen mindestens sein muss damit die
vermutung für die in der tabelle
erfassten jugendlichen zutrifft
ich brauche eine auszeit es macht keinen
sinn
doch wenn ich das abitur in fünf tagen
bestehen will muss ich jetzt durchziehen
und das tue ich auch bei den
übungsaufgaben erreiche ich jetzt schon
immer circa 70 prozent und damit wird
dieses kapitel fürs erste geschlossen
da kannst du jetzt leider zeitlich ist
ein bisschen schwierig ich muss ein
bisschen was arbeiten und dann werde
auch die motivation also da und jetzt
habe ich auf jeden fall nur noch ein
paar stunden für geometrie zeit und
morgen geht es dann direkt an den
endgegner analysis hierfür gibt es ganze
50 prozent aller möglichen punkte in
meinem abitur skript sind diesem thema
nicht wie bei statistik nur 18 seiten
gewidmet sondern ganze 47 also die
nächsten vier tage werde ich also dieses
team macht nonstop mit all seinen
unterpunkten durchkauen und ich habe
keinen bock stochastik habe ich am
wenigsten ein paar sachen richtig und
dann macht es auch ein bisschen spaß und
motiviert aber hier das wirklich ich
weiß aktuell wieder was ganz rationale
funktionen sind noch wie ich eine
funktion ableitet ich habe keine ahnung
wie ich eine pol stelle eine asyl tote
oder einen wendepunkt bestimmen und bei
integralrechnung also beim berechnen des
flächen inhalts zwischen zwei funktionen
da ist ein komplett vorbei aber diese
komplexeren sachen nicht zu können ist
auch nicht mal das schlimmste
hier mangelt es an den absoluten basics
weder die dynamischen formen habe ich im
kopf noch weiß ich wie man eine
definitions menge bestimmt und selbst
einfach errechnen und umformung regeln
die man schon in der achten klasse lernt
konnte ich entweder nie oder habe ich
innerhalb von wenigen tagen nach meiner
letzten mathestunde vor vier jahren
vergessen aber das wird sich jetzt in
den nächsten vier tagen nonstop kopf
gegen die wand maturanten ende
[Musik]
so lange war das jetzt zehn minuten
warum wie motiviert man sich etwas
wichtiges zu tun als in seinem körper
leider nicht den hauch von intrinsische
motivation hervorruft keine ahnung ich
weiß ja auch nicht ich mache jetzt
einfach der abend vor der prüfung ich
bin echt mega nervös
ich habe wirklich vor dem simulierten
abi morgan märz ist also ich vor meiner
eigenen abschlussprüfung hatte
[Musik]
ich habe ja eine ganze woche darauf
vorbereitet dürfen jetzt vor 100.000 den
leuten zu blamieren
hey wenn nicht jetzt nicht schaffen
nachdem nicht so zuversichtlich war der
finale test ist gekommen jetzt zählt
jetzt müsste es eigentlich locker
flockig schön durch rasiert werden
können
ich bin staat keine hilfsmittel für
diesen teil 19 minuten ab jetzt da es
ging relativ gut ich glaube das stimmt
ermitteln sie die neue studie der
funktion f das wird wieder ein logo
rhythmus ich sie selbst schon abruf ich
habe da ein rechenfehler -30 06 ist ja
gar nicht - 15 nicht um stochastik das
muss richtig gut werden so das ist auch
echt leicht verwirrt
wie kommen sie darauf dass nicht so
leicht aber jetzt weiß es kann ich den
kopf ausrechnen
ja das könnte hinein alle ich raff
geometrie gar nicht da also hier hätte
ich wirklich mehr als nur einen tag
machen sollen da ist auch schon ab okay
das war's dann wohl mit teilhabe
geometrie einfach nichts zeit geht ab
jetzt an alles ist aufgekommen war mir
auf ich bin gerade etwas unfertig und am
liebsten einfach schlafen jetzt kommt
die gelebte stochastik aber ich kann
mein körper war erst einmal vorbei glaub
ich muss ganz kurz mal pause machen
die aufgabe wird auch nichts drastisches
fertig letztlich gar nicht so
geschrieben jetzt kommt dietrich hat
auch 35 minuten
ich habe jetzt noch zwei minuten über
den zweck gehabt laufen mir fehlen noch
unfassbar viele aufgaben
mir ging es echt richtig schlecht im
sinne von körperlich und geistig da ist
es dann wieder wegreißt wenn ich nicht
irgendeine gute note hätte abgesehen von
geometrie war ich richtig stark aber nur
mit hoffnung und 20 prozent aus egal wir
werden gleich sehen das geht jetzt also
die korrektur und dann haben wir da geht
es egal was ich jetzt habe wohl mein
gott diese last von den schultern fällt
hauptsache ist vorbei also wie sieht's
aus also bei tna analysis hast du 10 5
punkte
teilweise wirklich überrascht also ich
sag mal so eine woche wollte auch nicht
läuft und man wird auch immer ein
bisschen süchtig nach den abgaben
wenn man so viel schon gerechnet hat
genauso wie ich wirklich stressig hast
du 95 punkte erreicht ach das ist ja
wirklich fast volle funktion gewesen
abgas biometrie habe ich im gedächtnis
das ist ja nicht ganz so gut war
bewertung einheiten teil b stars dabei
an alles ist 24 bewegungseinheiten das
ist aber okay und bei tebe stochastik da
hast du einen neuen bewegungs einheiten
von 20 leider nur hat es auch schlecht
also dann wird aber richtig knapp jetzt
insgesamt
da wird julia wir selber richtig knapp
jetzt muss das geometrie nach hoffen bei
geometrie hast du hier bewährt uns
anhalter als ob 57 ab 54 gibt's die 5
die punktlandung war wieder genau kein
handspiel gemacht als möglich perfekt
gesagt sie sind gegen eine sache ne zeit
aber ist also schon in meinem fach abi
hatte ich nur 3 1 träumt langsamer so
minimale aufwand für ja im zweifel
letzten hatte abi ich sage mal so fünf
punkte ist standen kann man jetzt auch
nicht sagen
let's go den link zum abitur skript mit
denen ich gelernt habt findet ihr ein
video beschreibung die nächste woche
kommt ein video in dem ich eine woche
lang online casino ausprobieren und der
forscher wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
und mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte
dann abonniert mich gerne schaut auch
auf inseln vorbei dafür die der
exklusive einblicke schon bevor das
video und dann kommt in meine
experimente und hier gibt es noch ein
anderes cooles experiment macht's gut
[Musik]